[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy friday my little friday friends
we'll get to the written house verdict
in a bit
but first the truly hard news president
joe biden underwent a colonoscopy
i believe we have exclusive tape of the
procedure
thank god thank god they found nothing
bad in his colon well except for his
head
it was a tough procedure for the doctors
they didn't know which end to work on
so they brought in a veterinarian they
needed someone experienced with a
horse's ass
of course that meant during the
procedure this person was in charge
what do you want to know
yep she was just a polyp away from the
presidency
in other news the dems and the media are
enraged i know surprise also the earth
is round the sky is blue and i'm
handsome
so what set them off was it rising crime
broken supply chain joe pooping in the
sink again
no something even more serious a
republican posted a meme yes a meme
quick let's convene a crooked panel made
up of left-wing psychos to condemn it
a sickening pose by a sitting member of
congress
paul gosar is is is a bigot with uh some
serious mental issues congressman gosar
is the death threat anime guy is that
really just a joke
it's the only way this guy seems to like
the joke he's constantly threatening
people in the other party no you're not
supposed to do that and it's not funny
and the kids don't care about your anime
it was not good what did they let
anybody run for congress
buddy anybody can run so they uh had a
vote to censor him over a meme once
again tackling the real issues that
affect the average hard-working
tax-paying citizen
now the last time i checked amim didn't
one demand that activists get in your
faces if you don't if things don't go
your way politically they didn't excuse
the burning down of businesses
redefining crime as protest leaving
dozens dead and causing more damage than
brian stelter at the golden corral
a meme didn't call for the targeting of
parents concerned over the brainwashing
of their kids a meme didn't separate
kids by race so they start at the
earliest age to hate each other amin
didn't push to defund the police all
over the country leaving a void that
thugs happily exploited who did all that
well i'll give you a hint it wasn't a
meme
it wasn't a wacky dentist like gozar by
the way he can't be any wackier than my
dentist who once told me that water
picks aren't just for teeth anymore
and he was right
shout out to the er
sure whatever gosar did was stupid i
guess because for a brief moment he
acted like a democrat right
but getting the dems to play by their
own rules that's like pulling teeth now
i still haven't even seen the actual
meme although immediately after he was
censored he retweeted it that's my type
of guy well that and brazilian underwear
models
and why didn't i see the meme i tend not
to look at the stupid stuff online if
i'm in a mood for deranged ramblings
i'll flip through cat's diary
she doesn't know i have my own key
the fact is like my affair with whoopi
goldberg no one would have known about
the meme until the media amplified it
and they do that as a diversion from
their own actual mayhem we live in an
era where the media and the activist
class actively subvert civil society
while attempting to destroy those who
try to stop them so forgive me if i
don't join the dems in their feverish
outrage over something you realize like
the moon landing or calmly smile isn't
real
like a meme it's like getting angry
arguing about whether santa claus is
black or white i couldn't care less if
the democrats post memes i wouldn't care
if they posted mimes at least mimes know
when to shut the [ __ ] up right
meanwhile they just put the q on shaman
behind bars for nearly four years his
crime showing up dressed like a viking
and scampering around the capitol like a
high school senior emptying lockers on
the last day of school in other words he
was acting just like the people who
actually work in the capital the other
364 days a year as the babylon bee noted
if only he burned down a car dealership
he would have gotten a lighter sentence
or his own flavor of ice cream from ben
and jerry's but who's going to fight for
him and call him an activist no one i
guess i could point out the hypocrisy in
all of this but why when colorado
congresswoman lauren bobert
already did it
but since the speaker has designated the
floor to discuss members inappropriate
actions
shall we
the jihad squad member from minnesota
has paid her husband and not her brother
husband the other one over a million
dollars in campaign funds this member is
allowed on the foreign affairs committee
while praising
terrorists my colleague and three-month
presidential candidate from california
who is on the intelligence committee
slept with fang fang a chinese spy
[Laughter]
excuse me lady but making fun of omar
and fartman swalwell are you trying to
take my job
if lauren starts calling cat a drug
addict i'm suing for copyright
infringement
in fact his incendiary language can only
go one way it's purely acceptable for
libs to excuse real aggression
if you see anybody from that cabinet in
a restaurant
in a department store
at a gasoline station you get out and
you create
[Applause]
i want to tell you cavanaugh you have
released the whirlwind and you will pay
the price there you go
and it's also part of the media's
mission
please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite and
peaceful because i can show you that
outraged citizens are the ones who have
made america what she is it's car
written house trial
it reminded a lot of people of something
the brett kavanaugh hearings in america
there's a thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
white tears
so what you're saying is you guys better
shut up while we can get more in your
face than nancy pelosi's team of
surgeons
step back and let's look at everything
right manipulating video to attack
covington catholic school kids the
targeting of parents the imprisoning of
the january 6 rioters for years the
media's distortion of the rittenhouse
case and targeting judge and jury and
remember the whip story where the left
and the dems attempted to ruin a border
patrol officer by lying about him
whipping migrants president biden said i
promise you those people will pay but
like most of his promises and his
digestion it was nothing but hot air
where the hell did that story go right
it's harder to find than mitch
mcconnell's chin
and why are we letting why are we
letting the mob off the hook hey
republicans grow some balls
whose side are you on anyway and of
course there's this entire hoax designed
to undermine an election because the
media not only hated the winner but they
hated his voters more
much of the dossier has been
corroborated when you look at just what
has become public
some of the public information is very
much in line with what is reported in
that dossier the three core goals that
are outlined in that dossier by that
particular source do seem to be very
well borne out much of the dossier has
been corroborated if you look at one of
the memos from comey written in february
of 2017 he effectively says that large
portions of the steele dossier have been
corroborated the dossier has been
corroborated there are parts of the
dossier that really have been proven out
yeah oh poor thing
it's pretty clear the left is losing so
they gotta fight dirty target instill
fear and if anyone fights back use
political and media power to destroy
them so i kind of forgive people like
goes-r for posting stupid memes they're
new with this game but it's a game the
dems and the media have been perfecting
for years but the game clock is running
out and they're about to suffer a huge
loss but hey maybe they can blame that
on a meme
let's welcome tonight's guests
she's our go-to financial expert when we
need money for lunch host of the evening
edit on fox business elizabeth mcdonald
he's our second favorite greg on the
show tonight after and author of the
great new book that responded greg ellis
he's a handsome combat vet who makes all
his fans sweat host of the podcast rob
smith is problematic rob smith
gucci chanel prada just a few stores
she's barred from entering foxy's
contributor catch him
so
uh rob
that was like a seven minute monologue
but really all i could have just said is
memes are stupid but so what
yeah so the thing about this story is
that look it was a stupid meme and
they're all blowing this up about aoc
her
face was on the image for like a split
second but if you listen to aoc she has
just cheated death more times than
superman right true so she's always
talking about you know how this is
causing everybody to come after her i
just think that it's
very very much overblown yeah yeah what
did you make of this greg
we've you've been here many times yes
and we always do a story about how the
media gets things wrong but
they do
so we have to cover that too often yes
too often who's going to hold them to
account i'm holding you account for that
jacket what yes well the print yeah
i'm sorry i just i just got taken it
back but i get it it's uh it's certainly
a very subtle uh yes a piece of a tire
no it's it's a little nuts isn't it when
yeah when you like the back it almost to
me looks like uh some kind of cartoon
show mm-hmm you know the fan fang what i
don't know what the fang fang thing is
oh you know i was saying the squad and
they're all like it's all this parody
and they're all they've all looked like
they've lost the plot yeah i like the
fact that they're inept and incompetent
if in fact they get nothing done but the
problem is they actually try to do
things but i mean like sleeping with a
chinese spy list i stopped doing that
years ago yeah
yeah how are you doing by the way
how are you
i think i have some breaking news for
you i think they found hillary's emails
in biden's colonoscopy
i'm just kidding
i like it she said
i'm just kidding
i still say that after years and years
right
now i'm kidding you're literally good
you'll get back checked yeah
right you'll get five penalties
msnbc right away oh that's what they
found it is to call it his colon five
pinocchios by pinocchio's and hillary's
evil yeah anyway so you know i looked at
that meme it's a cartoon it doesn't even
rank him up a hannah barber or mcgill a
gorilla yeah and he tries to make him go
sorry like he's thor but he's a flying
thor yeah but he's not i mean the
tedious orgy of self-righteousness from
nancy pelosi and aoc aoc humble bragging
this is not about me when she's
complaining to pelosi it is about her
right and she's saying this is about you
know who we are about all right so
broken borders right 150 countries
coming in
thousands from russia mideast yeah right
fentanyl enough to kill each and every
one of us yeah so that's really so it's
you know what i mean so it's let's talk
about and be outraged over a cartoon but
not what the real issues are yeah that's
the that's the whole point and it drives
me crazy because their entire ideology
is kind of based on the fact that
because the political is personal that
makes their enemies important and then
that that justifies the looting as
restorative justice kat um
what what are your thoughts there's so
many things from that brilliant
monologue well yeah i just wanna
i wanna make sure you're okay you know
because
you found out that joe biden was getting
a colonoscopy today after you already
wrote your monologue this is true and i
know that
you're pretending that you're okay
but i know that you're
not and it's okay to be vulnerable and
i'm here for you yes
it was quite a it was it was quite a
shock because as you know we've been
involved in this poop joke controversy
and we've been you know doing a lot of
background research on whether the poop
jokes are actually having a positive
effect on society yes that i think they
do i think and then what happens is like
i'm gonna do a monologue about like how
the media chases memes as opposed to
mayhem and then he goes and gets a
colonoscopy i know and i know there's
nothing i can say
there's nothing i can say to make you
feel better okay but i you know i'm just
thoughts and prayers yeah thoughts
yes this is poop gate this but by the
way
how do we really know it was a
colonoscopy
see this is what he wanted to do for
seven minutes yes
so here's the thing is it still
happening right now because during the
colonoscopy if he's under that means
kamala harris is technically president
that's right
that's the chill that everybody felt and
i think he did it perfectly before
thanksgiving because he could say i had
a full meal and it was no inflation at
my table
that's the worst part about colonoscopy
is you got to drink that fluid and then
just oh yeah it's just absolutely should
i get to that graphically you want to i
really want to i really want to
well either way if when the colonoscopy
is over biden will still be full of it
you know either way
there you go